I actually don't think women are  happiest being entrepreneurs and being  in the workplace I really do think they  are happiest when they're in their  feminine energy which means being taken  care of but also taking care of her  husband supporting her husband taking  care of children being nurturing I think  that's where women are most happiest and  actually sometimes it takes getting much  older and experiencing all of it to  realize like I saw someone doing some  Street interviews about this topic and  all these young women were like no I  want a career I want to Career all the  older women that had done it that's her  man I was like no I want a rich man to  take care of me